josh lindbloom
looking for his second win yeah and
again one and two that 6 31 earned run
average he's giving up some runs
ground ball to third
they'll get one
and two
double played in the inning even with
the bobble tiger's starting pitcher is
michael flomer the first thing with
michael is health can he stay healthy is
the knee going to be okay is the elbow
the arm gonna be okay
the payoff
see you later
former strikes out the side and leaves
two on base
left-handed batters are hitting 316
five home runs in 55 at bets
and also nine walks fly ball right field
way back and right and go on a home run
back of the wall of the bullpen in right
center kristen stewart number three
and the tigers take the one nothing lead
here in the third would you say he's a
good low ball hitter that was a sweet
fastball down about knee-high inner half
of the plate
severe buggy whip it went out in a hurry
[Applause]
another 3-2 and he walked him
good a-b huh sure was
2 30 this year with a little more power
the one-two swing a line drive into left
field and that's gonna drop for a base
hit back to fielded on a couple of skips
as stuart gamble's going for two throw
to second base is on the money and they
got him
terrific throw from kristen stewart to
cut down ben gamel on what looked like a
leadoff double
tell you what good swing
but kristen stewart was all over it and
what a throw i'll tell you what he's
improved in left field we've told you
that before but he got over he wheeled
and he threw he knew where he had to go
tigers would like those numbers to
improve with reunison score in position
01 to willy castro on the ground fair
that's going to find the right field
corner that drives in jones willie
castro's got wheels he's going to dig
for three already a double tonight
making a double and a triple as castro
continues to swing a hot stick for the
tigers
yeah he does have a good stick tigers
the organization love it
got him in the lineup again tonight now
you know why they want him in there
breaking ball it doesn't even flinch at
it long inning for josh lindbergh
25th pitch of the inning coming here
on a payoff to reyes
ripped to right
that'll drop in front of gamble another
run is home for the tigers and it's
victor reyes triggering a four nothing
lead
oh the two outs another run
here's the one two
swung on and missed
garcia goes down to start the fourth
it's the one two fastball got him on the
outside corner oh man daniel norris has
come out firing strikes called third on
narvaez major league debut of justin
topa
and he'll get
christian stewart grayson griner and
willie castro the bottom third of the
order for tulpa to the top of the order
for victor reyes reyes one of three
tigers
with a multi-hit game here
reyes drills one to deep right center
field that ball is gone
that's a massive blast
for victor reyes a two-run bomb there's
the add-on runs you wanted
it's six nothing tigers
okay he threw's 98 miles an hour but
very low he keeps the ball down and
victor is a good low ball hitter a
couple of strikeouts for yella chappie
not to see fulmer again
now the pitch
swings and drives one in the air to
right and deep get up
get up get out of here and gone
and they are on the board
the owlets goes out of here it's his
ninth of the year
on a 3-2 pitch
get it out of here
that was a
slider it looked like that kind of hung
up there a little bit and yell it's
right on it another solid night for
victor reyes the home run was his third
of the season and the o2
goes the other way ah another base hit
for victor reyes the hitting machine
just keeps on churning
he drives in two more and has a stand-up
two-run double here in the eighth tigers
have opened up a seven-run lead
victor's pulled the ball tonight
there's a couple singles
scope drills one to left
reyes will be waived home jonathan scope
has an rbi single make it 9-1 tigers
the 0-1 hammered to center that will
drop
and scope will try and score and he will
without a throw
double-digit runs for the tigers
and for orlando arcia
he gets to pitch
grinder sends one to deep left center
field that's got kerry and that's got
home run written all over it
a two-run bomb
from uh grayson griner
12-1 tigers
the o2 to nottingham
take strike three complete domination by
the tigers on this tuesday night in game
one
in milwaukee
12 runs on 14 hits